sind es roboter oder aliens die uns
angreifen und uns vernichten werden oder
ist es ein gigantischer ihnen einen
schlag oder gar ein atomkrieg der die
menschheit endgültig auslöschen wird ein
großes internationales forschungsteam
sagt jetzt das alles ist es nicht
sondern drei pandemien die auch noch
ineinander greifen und zu einer globalen
sünde me führen krieg zum science
fiction hier gibt es jeden tag spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal nur
dann verpasst ihr nichts herzlich
willkommen
[Musik]
ein bisschen erinnert mich das an die
warnungen des weltberühmten physiker
stephen hawking der uns immer wieder vor
augen gehalten hat welche faktoren zur
auslöschung der menschheit führen
könnten zum beispiel genetisch
veränderte viren ein atomkrieg oder
künstliche intelligenz ein großes team
aus internationalen wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftlern gibt rocking in
seiner aktuellen studie jetzt zum teil
recht und zwar sehen die fachleute die
existenz der menschheit aktuell durch
drei pandemien bedroht also weltweite
epidemie
das forschungsteam hat für ihre arbeit
mehr als 350 quellen ausgewertet und
eine der eingegrenzten katastrophalen
pandemien ist der klimawandel
ähnlich wie stalking eben einmal gesagt
hatte den autoren und autorinnen zufolge
werden umweltschäden ignoriert die durch
die derzeitigen ernährungssystem den
verkehr den städtebau und die
landnutzung verursacht werden
ein faktor also der das überleben der
menschheit riskiert und das einzig und
allein aus macht gier und finanziellen
und wirtschaftlichen erfolg laut der
fachleute aus 14 ländern könne der
klimawandel in diesem zusammenhang
durchaus als pandemie gesehen werden
schließlich habe er weitreichende
auswirkungen auf die gesundheit der
menschen und zudem auch auf die
gesundheit der erde passend also zur
definition des begriffes pandemie wo mit
dem engeren sinne ja eine krankheit
gemeint ist die sich über länder und
kontinente ausbreitet also nicht örtlich
begrenzt ist die beiden anderen
pandemien die das überleben der
menschheit gefährden sind demnach zwei
krankheiten die mit unseren
ernährungsgewohnheiten zu tun haben
unsere ernährung zum 1
zum anderen fettleibigkeit eigentlich ja
zwei krankheiten die gegensätzlicher
nicht sein könnten
doch einer der beteiligten forscher in
bern sieht das komplett anders
in wirklichkeit werden sie beide von den
gleichen ungesunden unangemessenen
ernährung systemen angetrieben die sich
ausschließlich auf das
wirtschaftswachstum konzentrieren und
die negativen folgen im hinblick auf die
gesundheit sowie die chancengleichheit
ignorieren es ist ja wirklich ein
verzerrtes system in dem wir leben
millionen von menschen auf unserer erde
haben nicht genug nahrung und leiden
unter unterernährung dagegen steht die
überproduktion und der enorme konsum der
in den westlichen ländern zu übergewicht
und fettleibigkeit wird fast zwei
milliarden menschen gelten weltweit als
übergewichtig oder fettleibig und die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
halten auch fest dass unsere
gesellschaft ebenso wie politiker und
regierung selbst ursprung dieses problem
sind denn der einfluss durch die
lebensmittelindustrie ist groß und
schlechte ernährungsgewohnheiten können
sich so durchsetzen so kommen die
fachleute zu der erkenntnis dass alle
drei pandemien zusammenhängen denn
ungesunde ernährung macht nicht nur uns
menschen krank sondern fördert zudem
auch noch den klimawandel als ursachen
dafür werden in der studie unter anderem
die landnutzung und die landwirtschaft
genannt große agrarbetriebe betreiben
monokulturen und nehmen dadurch unter
anderem das abholzen von wäldern schwere
umweltschäden und ein massives
artensterben als folgenden kauf das
forschungsteam warnt davor dass sich
diese drei pandemien klimawandel
fettleibigkeit und unterernährung zu
einer so genannten globalen sind demi
entwickeln das bedeutet in etwa so viel
wie ineinandergreifende
gesundheitsprobleme der studie zufolge
die größte gesundheitliche
herausforderung für mensch umwelt und
planet im einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert
die experten und expertinnen fordern
regierungen weltweit auf den einfluss
großer lebensmittelkonzerne zu
minimieren und verantwortung zu
übernehmen richtlinie und verträge
könnten den ländern dabei helfen eine
nachhaltige und gesunde lebensmittel
politik auszuarbeiten
zudem sei es notwendig unsere ernährung
systeme neu auszurichten und zwar
komplett
wünschenswert seien demnach
beispielsweise bessere informationen für
verbraucher und verbraucherinnen
etiketten beispielsweise die genau
auflisten welche zusätze in stark
weiterverarbeiteten produkten enthalten
sind dazu geben die autoren und
autorinnen eine sehr eindrückliche
warnungen heraus schönheitsreparaturen
an der oberfläche werden nicht die
ergebnisse liefern die die welt für das
21 jahrhundert braucht sorry wenn wir
hier wieder mal panik verbreiten wir ja
manchmal kritisiert wird aber es gibt
halt keine forscherinnen und forscher
die eine rosige zukunft ausmalen
klimawandel fakt oder fiktion für dieses
video hier klicken anschauen und
raumzeit block der zukunft abonnieren
bis dann bleibt dran